-We're about to do
something fun...
but I'm gonna need some help.
He is a music super star
and one of the judges
on the new show
"Becoming a Popstar,"
which premieres March 24th
at 10:00 PM on MTV.
Please welcome...
Joe Jonas!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on, man.
-[ Indistinct ]
-Come on.
That's Joe Jonas right there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's exactly right.
Joe and I are about to
do something brand-new.
This is "TikTok Duets."
Check it out.
-♪ "TikTok Duets" ♪
♪ "TikTok Duets" ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
-Now, a lot of people on TikTok
post videos
where they start singing a song
and then leave
the second verse empty,
and anyone can film
the next verse
with their own made-up lyrics
to duet with them.
It's Open Verse Challenge.
So we're gonna do that
right now, okay?
I'm gonna start us off.
-Okay.
-My first duet...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...is called --
My first duet is call--
The first duet is called "Don't
Text Me When You're Drunk,"
by Stacey Ryan.
Alright. Here we go.
-♪ Please don't text me
when you're drunk ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
♪ Or don't text me at all ♪
♪♪
-♪ I'm sorry for the texts ♪
♪ That I sent you late
last night at 2:00 AM ♪
♪ I guess it didn't make
much sense when I said ♪
[ Vocalizing ]
♪ I just expected ♪
♪ It to autocorrect it ♪
♪ And then I sent a text
that was longer than before ♪
♪ It said,
"Hey, wadsupsdfq7834" ♪
♪ So when you looked
at your phone to find ♪
♪ 40 texts
and 8 missed FaceTimes ♪
♪ It makes sense ♪
♪ I've been blocked ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Indistinct ]
We'll give him two thumbs-up.
-I got two thumbs-up.
-She liked it.
-Okay, this is --
it's your turn.
Your TikTok duet is called
"Closer" by Tristan Price.
-Okay.
-Whenever you're ready.
-♪ Baby, baby, baby ♪
♪ I wanna get to know ya ♪
♪ So come a little closer ♪
♪ 'Cause, baby,
tonight I just want ya ♪
-♪ Wait, I thought we were
already pretty tight? ♪
-♪ We've known each other
since we were five ♪
♪ Our moms are in
the same book club ♪
♪ Baby photos of us
in the same bathtub ♪
♪ And you have
all of my logins ♪
♪ Netflix, Hulu, and something
called "Watch It" ♪
♪ You know about
my lower back birth mark ♪
♪ I thought that made us pretty
close, but I guess not ♪
♪ No, no, no, no ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Your lower back...
Your lower back birth mark?
-Yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
-It's the first time I told
everyone on TV.
-And our moms are in
the same book club. Come on.
I guess you weren't
as close as you thought.
Alright. Here we go.
This last one, we're gonna
do a TikTok duet together.
Our last song...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...is "All For You"
by Cian Ducrot.
Here we go.
-♪ But now I'm just
a little too late ♪
♪ To be what you needed,
but I hope that he is ♪
♪♪
-♪ Wait, are you talking
to him or to me? ♪
-♪ 'Cause wearing sunglasses
inside's hard to see ♪
-♪ Are you asking if I'm
what he needs? Or reverse? ♪
-♪ See, this is why
I wanted us to rehearse ♪
-♪ He said he'd be late,
that's thoughtful, not rude ♪
-♪ But what do we call
a duet with three dudes? ♪
-♪ Joe, you're a Jonas Bro,
I should ask you ♪
-♪ Three dudes ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
We did it! Joe Jonas!
More with Joe Jonas
after the break!
♪ Stick around, we'll be right
back with the show ♪